[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 ya me acompaña a nuestra mesa
de trabajo Marta Moya Marta bienvenida
iniciamos la semana con la noticia de
nuestro continente que son por supuesto
los resultados de la primera vuelta de
las elecciones generales en Brasil el
tema con la que abre toda la prensa
local de ese país Así es bueno soy Raúl
empezamos con la de Sao Paulo que
titula este lunes bolsonaro demuestra
fuerza y el presidente va a segunda
vuelta con Lula Este es un titular
recurrente entre toda la prensa dijo
dice esta portada de la que Lula
aventaja por 6 millones de votos a
bolsonaro y que fue una jornada con
episodios aislados de violencia y largas
colas que esto puede reflejar Pues que
los resultados tardarán un poco más en
emitirse que dice Extra extra exclama
halla corazón un poco En referencia a
esta polarización y a estos resultados
que son más estrechos de los que como
las encuestas habían previsto este este
periódico muestra una foto del cara a
cara entre los dos candidatos y sostiene
después de un duelo frente a frente
entre Lula y bolsonaro con un sorpasso
hacia el final del escrutinio los dos
llegan al balotaje no va a faltar
emoción en la prórroga y que dice el
estado de Sao Paulo Marta el estado de
Sao Paulo titula bolsonarova segunda
vuelta con Lula con más votos de lo
previsto como decíamos un titular
recurrente en toda la prensa brasileña
dice que el presidente exhibió más
fuerza de la que habían pronosticado los
sondeos y que el electorado del centro
será clave el día 30 que es cuando
tendrá lugar el balotaje estado de minas
el estado de minas titula un país
dividido un titular que no deja lugar a
dudas de esta gran polarización que
enfrenta el país en estas en estas
próximas cuatro semanas de Cara a la
segunda vuelta dice que aunque Lula
lidera bolsonaro salió fortalecido por
una votación
fallaron Pues los sondeos de opinión
vamos con las portadas de nuestro
continente de toda América Latina Y
empezamos con la nación en Argentina Así
es la nación titula ganó Lula pero
bolsonaro fue la gran sorpresa y habrá
balotaje Lula superó por 5 puntos al
presidente pero pues como decíamos la
diferencia es mucho menos grande que la
prevista en los sondeos además dice en
su análisis que los dos rivales se creen
victoriosos y muestran esa portada pues
la imagen de los dos candidatos seguimos
en Argentina Marta con Clarín El Clarín
titular Lula ganó Por poco y no le
alcanzó va a segunda vuelta con
bolsonaro anticipan el balotaje
impredecible para el 30 de octubre y
dice que bolsonaro no O sea no
desconoció el resultado como había
amenazado que lo haría durante mucho
tiempo la tercera en Chile en Chile
titulan bolsonaro da la sorpresa pierde
por un estrecho margen ante Lula y
consigue la segunda vuelta y milenio en
México titulan se cae la ventaja de Lula
e irá a segunda vuelta con bolsonaro
todos los medios que reflejan Pues esta
victoria de Lula Pero quizá la noticia
del día como se destacan en los
titulares es que bolsonaro pues
consiguió un resultado mucho más
ajustado seguimos Marta hablando por
supuesto de Brasil porque está no es
tanto dentro como fuera del país sino
también en toda la comunidad
internacional todos los países alrededor
del mundo analizan piezas de opinión
alrededor de nuestro globo de Guardian
que dice el de Guardian hace un
explainer que titula porque el resultado
del domingo fue tan decepcionante para
la izquierda Y dice Bueno analiza un
poco las claves de la jornada de ayer y
dice que los izquierdistas del partido
de los trabajadores esperaban pues una
victoria con un margen mucho más amplio
y que le diera impulso de Cara a la
segunda vuelta Los progresistas cito
textualmente de todo el mundo estaban
atentos a un repudio enfático a la
presidencia de bolsonaro Pero eso no así
bolsonaro además como veníamos
comentando y los noticieros ha obtenido
una mayoría en el legislativo senado y
cámara de diputados y bueno destaca este
artículo del the Guardian que la tensión
política pudo haber sido uno de las
causantes a este más del 20% de
abstensión de abstensión y que la
victoria de Lula fue amarga porque
aunque se espera que gane según las
encuestas puede Hacerlo con un margen
más estrecho que daría pie a un discurso
antidemocrático y belicista de bolsonaro
que ya como decíamos ha amenazado con no
reconocer los resultados el país de
España el país de España hace un
análisis que titula un país partido y
dice que la segunda vuelta se dará en un
clima de extrema polarización dice
textualmente en la historia mundial de
los gatillazos de moscópicos la de estas
elecciones brasileñas tienen un lugar de
honor sostiene dos escenarios o bien las
encuestadoras fallaron estre realmente
analizando a bolsonaro porque con Lula
si acertaron o bien los brasileños
mintieron deliberadamente la distancia
que dibujan las encuestas del resultado
marca la diferencia entre un país que
quería coser las heridas y la realidad
que es un país totalmente dividido carta
capital Marta este periódico brasileño
de izquierda titula en la primera o
segunda vuelta la elección de 2022 marca
la derrota del bolsonarismo dice Bueno
pues que bolsonaro perdió la capacidad
de mantener la hegemonía en redes
sociales que fue un poco una de los
ingredientes que le dio la victoria en
2018 y Bueno pues la popularidad de Lula
que a la que se sumaron pues grandes
figuras mediáticas en Brasil sumado Pues
a la bueno acción del tribunal superior
electoral hizo que bolsonaro perdiera
esta hegemonía y además no consiguió
revertir sus dos principales
deficiencias como son el apoyo las más
pobres de Brasil y además el apoyo de
las capas medias en el suroeste seguimos
analizando este tema con nuestra primera
invitada del día Marta Gracias Hasta
mañana hasta mañana